Okay, week five.
Um, thought I'd begin tonight by just seeing if anybody,
um, would be willing to just share something
that you got out of either week fives material
or week four.
Just anybody have a takeaway from either
of those past two weeks?
We're gonna go over the material in week five,
somewhat tonight, but just in case just kind of wondering
what, if there's anything that's kind of speaking to you.
And no shame if there isn't. Uh,
We, we five that's we're Now, right? Yes. Yeah. It
Didn't seem like it really flowed the way the other
lessons have, at least to us.
Yeah. It seemed like it jumped around a lot.
It actually has two major focuses,
or folk, I, whatever, you know, you say that.
Um, one being condemnation, emptying your cups
of condemnation.
And then the other is sexual intimacy in marriage.
So that might've been part of that. I'm not sure.
Like there was,
I think two days and sexual
intimacy was right in the middle.
And then we go up and pick up another topic.
Yeah. Yeah. It, it kind of does that.
I think this is the first time it's really had two major
topics, Uhhuh,
but, um, it always has some days that are more about, uh,
your, your relationship or, uh, intimacy with Jesus.
Um, and then other days that are more specifically on
a relationship as a couple, so
that there's a little bouncing around
that's intentional every week.
But I think it probably added to that
because they had two days on sexual intimacy
and two days on, or three
or four days that would've been on condemnation.
So I'm, I'm gonna try to cover both of those areas. Okay.
Uh, before I do that, anybody else want to share anything?
I like the, Go
Ahead. I like the thought
in, um, the one Corinthians 13
and changing out the name, our names for love.
Yeah. I actually took that and wrote it on our mirror
because that made an impact for me.
I feel like that was something that I could kind
of grab hold of and kind
of remind myself throughout the day, am I doing this
Good? So
I, I really enjoyed that part
Of it. Yeah.
If I could build off that, um,
uh, back when I was a younger man
and had hair, uh, I was in seminary
and I had, I took a class on spiritual formation, which was
probably my most memorable class of three years
of schooling there.
And, uh, one of the things that the, uh, professor
of that class did was, he had us go through Psalms
on our own, but he said, replace your name,
um, as if you're David writing those psalms.
So read it or even read it out loud,
but personalize it, make it first person.
And that really did make a difference.
And you reminded me of that as you said that, so
Very good, very good way to apply that.
Anybody else?
I was gonna say back to week four, so one
of the things I've struggled with for 20 plus years
of marriage is the trying to fix everything.
Right? Like, that's my job. Mm-Hmm.
Day to day, that's what I do. I'm a fixer.
I I manage things and have done it for years and years.
And so it's really hard for me to just sit and listen
and sit and mourn with her and Mm-Hmm.
You know, feel her feelings when that's not
what she wants for sure.
But even more, that's not what she needs. Mm-Hmm.
And so we, we had a really good conversation on, okay,
how do I get them past that?
And, you know,
because there's still that time as we talked, even
for weeks on the, um, uh, you know, speaking the truth
and love Mm-Hmm.
And, you know, it's, I still find myself challenging
to bite my tongue and,
and hopefully getting to the point of I'm not having
to fight that in my own mind
because I'm already seeing that's not even what I should be
focusing on to begin with. Mm-Hmm.
And that's a great takeaway.
Uh, high five, right, Carrie? Uh, very helpful. Yes.
Yeah. And it's, uh, it is so common,
not exclusively to men,
but probably more likely that we'll see ourselves
as fixers and doers and so forth.
Well, I think we also, I mean, the question
that you asked me, 'cause he was like, how do I know when
to say I think you should do this
versus, I'm just gonna listen.
So we had a whole discussion on like, what would
that look like, Uhhuh, like
Did you, did you figure that Out?
Yeah, we decided we'd come up with like,
just continue these meetings.
Like, that would be the time that I'm saying, Hey,
I need you to help me fix this, versus I need you
To listen.
And I mean, just verbally saying that instead
of having expectations or Yeah.
Um, not feeling heard,
but just, um, so he knows too, like, how,
how can he help me in that way?
And how can I help him? And
how can we communicate better things?
Yeah. It was really good.
You know, uh, the mentor
that you've seen David Ferguson on these, uh, videos, uh,
helped us, uh, also see that
as almost a general problem in our culture as well
as most cultures in the world, which is we have a being
with issue.
We struggle to be with people where we're really connecting
emotionally, psychologically, relationally.
So we can do things and we can fix problems
and that kind of deal.
But it is hard, especially if that wasn't part of
what you experienced on a regular daily, weekly basis
in your young years.
'cause that's where you're just absorbing everything,
whatever's there is what you're absorbing.
Right. In my home, as I've said
before, it was overall very good family
and very stable and all that.
But we did not discuss emotions ever
just wasn't on the agenda.
So you learn by experience.
Um, if I'm feeling something I'm,
maybe I shouldn't be feeling something, you know?
So you just learn to not communicate it.
Uh, and definitely if somebody starts crying
in my presence and I'm married to her, if that were
to happen, that makes me doubly anxious
because now that looks like a problem to me.
And in a way it is. But I just had
to learn the very same thing.
And my mid forties was the best thing to do is
what the Bible says to do, which is be with her hurting,
with her mourning, with her tuning in
with her emotions rather than trying
to take it somewhere else as a diversion.
And if I could add one thing, we, we, uh,
we were talking earlier about a, um, a train we had earlier,
and one of the things that came up was that the,
the opposite almost of being with Mm-Hmm.
Is being around. And I think so often we kind
of put into our minds where we're with them,
but we're not, we're just around them.
And, uh, you know, keeping that as a mindset of that has
to be the difference of I'm not just around you, I'm
with you, and what the different things
that can mean and how we do that. So
Yeah. Even if we just think
about something that's not sinful,
unless you're watching really bad stuff or something,
but if you're watching TV together
now, that's not a bad thing.
Right. Uh, we had a great time watching
sports this weekend together,
but that rarely accomplishes being with, that's good,
but it's not the same.
And we need this be with me, see my heart, understand me,
um, be, be, uh,
caring for me rather than managing me.
So, good takeaways. Yeah.
If you've got nothing outta this class, then that, uh,
that would probably, uh, uh, be a great investment
of your time already. Anybody else?
I would add, I'd say that I would say had to as well, um,
connect with that in the sense that
in my childhood growing up,
my parents divorced when I was young,
and then they remarried later on
and out of, so I don't remember
as much from the early childhood
and it wasn't a healthy spot anyways,
but the older marriages, the best out of both
of those was the marriage where my stepfather said that
he liked my, my mom being with,
and he just met in the same household, Uhhuh with her.
And so that was the closest thing
that I saw for the most part.
Yeah. To connection. Yeah.
Uh, other than occasionally we would go on a family vacation
or something like that, but, um, it was like, that was what,
that was the depth of what he under it seemed to me like.
Mm-Hmm. From my view at least, that
that was probably the depth of
what he understood of being with.
Right. Um, and he was on his third marriage
and different things, but yeah.
Um, so I don't think that I really, and I,
and I've talked to my wife about that.
I like her being with me Mm-Hmm.
With different activities where they're working on something
or playing or vacation or whatever.
I don't care. I like her being with me. Yeah.
Um, but I would like the more also mm-Hmm.
So, but anyways, it's just interesting. Great.
When you haven't seen the other, it's hard to, it's hard to
figure out how to get to something you've never
really understood.
So, Mm-Hmm.
That's really good. Yeah.
I bet you there's others in the room
that could probably relate directly to some of
that in different details. But, uh,
And for that he, your comfort
that he never got
and see you. Interesting.
So I'm just gonna repeat what Joyce said, make sure
that it's picked up on here, that that's anytime
needs that God wanted met for us growing up, such as empathy
and compassion, comfort, encouragement,
if those weren't met, that's another memory
that may be waiting for some of God's comfort.
And his comfort is not a pep talk. It is.
I care that you did not have that,
and maybe even, and I think I can even try harder
to give that to you as we go forward.
In other words, I'm gonna learn from
this if I haven't already.
Hope for the future. Hope for the future. Yeah. Mm-Hmm.
Um, one of the things that's implied in many
of these weeks is, uh, the need that we might have
for change or growth
in our ability to love.
Well, okay.
And I sure hope, in fact,
we're gonna talk about condemnation night.
Don't be going around beating yourself up.
Especially if it wasn't like, well,
I just don't really think I care, and
therefore I'm just not going to give to this relationship.
That would be more of an attitude
that needs changing, right?
Mm-Hmm. But oftentimes it's inadequacy. Join the club.
Um, even
after I was trained to be a counselor, I had not learned how
to, uh, communicate with my wife's heart.
Now that's really scary.
If you're her, you know,
he's even got a counseling degree now,
and I still wasn't communicating with her heart.
And, uh, there was a need for awareness
that I need to grow.
And secondly, there was a need for effort to make
that growth, to kind of get on board with
what the Lord was doing.
So, more good comments.
So realize this, this blushy, this comfort thing,
uh, which is so foreign to many of us as far as
what we were exposed to,
or what we've experienced, even sometimes in marriage,
like we had not experienced it.
Um, this is almost a daily opportunity,
either in marriage
or in other encounters you have
with other people during the day.
It's all around us that people are hurting.
So we just want to equip the saints for the work of
that ministry starting at home,
and then be ready for the people around you.
So, okay, let me pray for us,
and then I'm gonna give you a little talking
assignment as a couple.
Father, be with us today, uh, as we just continue
to reflect on the word, the instruction, the guidance
that you have given us about how to love, like Jesus loves,
uh, how to give first and, uh,
and speak truth in love,
but also, um, create safe places
for our spouses to share with us what they're thinking,
what they're feeling, what they're needing.
Um, and we know your, your Holy Spirit,
your already active in us
because it's, it's a gift from you.
So let us just respond to the nudges
that we get from the Spirit in Jesus' name.
Amen. So, um,
uh, Couple of thoughts.
We're gonna talk about condemnation first.
And, um, I'm gonna show you a
video of Dr. Ferguson doing another meditation.
Okay? This one's coming out of Romans eight,
so you'll probably be very familiar with the verse.
Romans eight, one that says, there is now,
therefore no condemnation
for those who are in Christ Jesus.
Basically saying, if you have put your trust in Christ,
receive him into your heart.
Um, he has made an eternal home for you
that he is not the one responsible it
for you feeling condemnation if you're still feeling it.
It's not coming from him according to that verse.
It's coming from tapes, memories, patterns
of thoughts that you may have had.
And it's not coming from him, but they may still be there.
And we would love for them to not be there to
where those thoughts, those feelings
that come from those thoughts are not haunting
you on a regular basis. If that makes sense.
Can I add something? Sure.
And for a long time, until I understood what condemnation,
how it could come into our lives, yours came from me.
What you might, you might already say what you mean. Yeah.
Well, like, I was quite, I was never satisfied,
or you got home too late again,
or, you know, stuff like that.
And that just makes you feel inadequate.
Yeah. And we, we had that awareness of
that part of our dynamic.
At that same point in our relationship, about 19 years in,
we were both about 45.
And then I think I've already shared how I would leave her
needing to talk and I'd be saying,
don't have time or something like that.
I was leaving her abandoned.
So we both had things that we were coming to be aware of.
And, uh, but it wouldn't have helped
if I continued to scratch that sore on her arm,
or she continues to step on the bruise
that I have from the condemnation I got growing up.
So coming to be aware of that,
and then having tools for how do we respond instead. So,
And it helps to know the personality
of your spouse versus you.
'cause like, I didn't gather
as much condemnation from my parents,
because when my mom would say, oh, you can't do that,
I would say, well, you just hide and watch.
Yeah. Have you noticed a little personality difference
between you bet
That you, you would go, oh gosh, I will never
satisfy her.
She'll never tell me she loves me. You know?
So sometimes there's personality differences.
Yeah. That factors in as well. For sure.
So, um, that verse,
Romans eight one, there's now
therefore no condemnation for those who are in Christ.
Jesus is a, is a declaration of God's truth.
It is true for every single believer.
But on the other hand, that verse in Romans, it says,
don't conform any longer to the patterns of this world,
but be transformed.
How? By the renewing of your mind,
do you realize the renewing of your mind is not just
what you think, it's healing of what you feel
that's real important is that's all part of your mind.
Okay? So what you think is very likely
triggering either good emotion
or bad emotion, depending upon what you're thinking.
And so we'd say, well, if I am continuing
to tell myself I'm stupid,
which was part of my vocabulary for myself for years,
I'm stupid, and I actually took that to heart
so I would feel bad.
Mm-Hmm. I'd feel condemned.
And do you think that influenced my behavior?
I you better believe it. And that was not coming from God.
He would've been saying,
you may not be the smartest cookie on the block,
but you're not stupid.
That's not what I, God would call you.
I would start with, you're my beloved son, along
with a bunch of others, but you are one of my beloved.
Okay? So let's watch this video.
And it's actually referring to the latter part
of Romans eight, where
the Apostle Paul wrote
as if he was describing a legal courtroom.
The terminology is almost like that of a courtroom.
So I'm gonna let David be the one that does that for you.
See if I can pull that up now.
I'm sorry, I lost
my there.
It's,
There we go.
It's not gonna work. This is
about three minutes long.
There's a very mysterious, uh,
passage in Romans chapter eight.
It talks about there is no condemnation for those of us
who are in Christ Jesus.
So one of the challenges that we find in life today is how
to experience more
and more freedom from those self-doubts,
from those self condemning thoughts.
And one of the ways to do that is to really, uh, deal with
who is it that can bring charge or condemnation toward us?
Too often in our day to day, we would say kind of anybody
and everybody who could, uh, you know, criticize me,
judge me, compared me.
Particularly in this world of social media
and all the comparisons that are happening out there today.
It's so easy to reinforce this condemnation, self blame
as comparisons are made, you see that power
of bringing charge has been given to the one Jesus Christ.
But the passage says, it's that one Jesus who's lived,
whose died, has been raised
and is now beautiful, present tense word, now
interceding for you.
Now that needs to bring a smile to your face,
that only one person
who can bring charge against you is praying for you.
And so, in just a moment, we're gonna meditate on
that kind of praying, Jesus.
And the scene that we're gonna allow the Holy Spirit
to paint inside of our hearts
and minds is the scene of a courtroom.
And so the imagery here is, of you
and I walking alone into
an unfriendly courtroom, would you bow with me?
And let's do that. Heavenly Father, uh,
we pray in these moments, there would be a fresh work
of the Holy Spirit to bring freedom from condemnation.
Would you imagine yourself walking
into a courtroom all alone?
You notice unfriendly faces are there,
there are people there who in the past have
judged or criticized you.
And now your uncertainty
and anxiety is even further increased.
But who is it really that can bring charge against you?
Would you imagine? Right now into
that courtroom walks Jesus Christ, he walks right into
that courtroom, puts his arm gently around you.
He begins to pray for you, begins to pray for the needs
of your life, the burdens of your heart.
He's praying your prayer list.
Allow the Holy Spirit to touch you with the wonder
of a praying Jesus who is so attentive, so knowing of you
that he is praying specifically
for the burdens and needs of your life.
And as you hear him pray,
would you imagine he whispers these words to you?
Where are your accusers?
And you open your eyes to look around
and all those unfriendly faces are gone.
And Jesus continues to pray.
And he prays these words, neither do I accuse you.
Would you allow the Holy Spirit to use that truth
to cast out any, any seeds of condemnation, any threads
of condemnation in your heart?
Any self-blame self-criticism?
Neither do I accuse you.
Take some time now to continue your Jesus story.
First, listen to his voice
and hear what he wants to say just for you.
And after you've heard from him,
respond back to him in a personal way.
Tell Jesus what's on your heart.
Allow the Holy Spirit to take this truth
of a praying Jesus deeply into your heart, that
that freedom might bring forth joy and wonder
and gratitude that it might lead to more
and more life abundant.
Do that we ask Jesus even now. Amen. Amen.
Experience more and more freedom from those self doubts,
from those self condemning thoughts.
Okay? So in just a minute, I'm going to let you share
with your spouse maybe what came to your thoughts
as you were listening to the meditation
or even hearing from the Lord.
Um, and remember that some
of you might have experienced something very good during
that time and that would be caused to
rejoice with him.
And some of you may have simply been reminded of some
of the hurt that you had experienced,
and that would call for compassion.
I care that you might still be dealing with some of
that and want you to know that I would not want to be
adding any condemnation to you.
So I want to, uh, give you a,
some verses that I have found very helpful.
Uh, I think there's enough of, for one, for everybody on
This one. So
I encourage you to go ahead and take one.
I've got some verses some things on the back,
but I'm not going to be using that now.
But, um, four verses that
will just give you some additional
truth to reflect on.
You know, it's one thing to try to stop
tapes from playing in my head
or my own voice, uh, judging me
and critical harsh ways, um,
keeping in mind that some of the most common ways
that a sense of I'm not enough
or, uh, I'm unlovable
or anything in that direction.
I'm stupid, I'm foolish, I'm a mess up.
All of those kinds of things.
Many times they have come from
extreme criticism in childhood.
That's where the seeds got planted.
We're not trying to blame everything on parents.
That could have come from bullies.
That could have come from people rejecting you
because you look different than they did,
or you were a nerd and they weren't.
Uh, all kinds of things.
But it often comes from extreme criticism.
It also can come from extreme neglect,
which is a little harder to spot sometimes.
But if you have legitimate God ordained needs
and they're not being provided for a need for security,
for example, if that's not being
provided, that's a form of something good that God wants you
to have, but it was not being provided.
And it's essentially neglect.
It's a need that's going unmet.
Um, so there's a lot of things.
Obviously abuse of any kind can contribute to a sense
of worthlessness or a sense of being unworthy,
uh, not valued.
Um, so,
and keep in mind, um, that
is not something God is calling you.
Do any of us deserve Jesus down on the cross?
First I'd say, no, we don't, we didn't do anything
or couldn't do anything to deserve that.
But God is not the one saying, you're not worth loving
because he loved us first.
That's proof. Okay?
So these are the verses we love because he first loved us.
Um, he didn't wait for you to perform before he loved you.
'cause Romans five, eight says that he actually,
while we were still sinners, was choosing to send his son
to a cross to die for us.
There is your proof that you weren't, you weren't,
he wasn't waiting for you to perform.
Okay. My favorite verse, one
of my favorite verses is Zephaniah three 17,
the Lord your God is with you.
The mighty warrior who saves,
he will take great, what's that word?
Delight in
you, in his love.
He will no longer rebuke you,
but he will rejoice over you with singing one
of the translations.
Not this particular one.
You, uh, phrases one of those sentences
as he will calm you with his love.
I love that. It's kind like when I'm all, I'm all
stressed out, he's saying, I got this.
Here's another one that says, if he will quiet
You with, quiet you with his love, thank you. Which
Means like, I can just imagine you,
you're projecting all this condemnation on yourself, right?
Yeah. Talking to yourself instead of preaching to yourself.
Yes. And now, and then he quiet s**t. Yeah. With his love.
You know, that's just so overwhelmed
and overpowers all that condemnation, right?
Yeah. With the, the words Romans eight, one. Yeah.
For instance, or something else
that when you start preaching to yourself Yeah.
Instead of listening
To yourself. I love that.
Yeah. I had not ever heard that particular
application, but I I totally agree with it.
Yeah. His love. And it's with his love.
He's just saying, I got this. We're good.
We're gonna make it. Okay. Sure.
To goodness and mercy
or love will follow me all the days of my life.
And I will go on the house of the Lord.
It's that, I think I might have mentioned this the previous
week, but he's following you.
He's not waiting for you.
And then, uh, the passage in John nine
that says he went
after the one who had been kicked out of the church.
We talked about that last time.
I think, uh, one other thing about David's meditation,
you might have noticed that he
actually included a reference.
He didn't name it, but he actually referred back to someone
who was being condemned by the religious leaders.
The woman caught in adultery.
I think that's John a And that's
where he literally said to her, uh,
after he had gotten rid of them by saying, okay, if you,
if you haven't ever sinned,
then you can start throwing your stone.
And they all left. Then he turns to her
and says, where are your accusers?
One translation actually says Condemners.
And she says, they've gone.
He says, neither do I condemn you. Go and say no more.
So take a moment thinking about those verses
as there is what your god's
attitude towards you is based on his own words.
But just share any thoughts that you have about your own
sense of struggle.
Or if you don't struggle with that, rejoice in that. Okay.
All right. And I know there's a couple
of you here without your spouses, if you guys want to just
pop over and share with each other a little bit,
that would be courageous. But,
Uh, Anyway, I leave that to you.
Okay. Go ahead and share.
We'll take about five minutes for this.
It's doing my civic duty.
I can, I can't figure out how to shut off the music.
I thought if I just checked out of that, it would do
That.
So notice when I couldn't figure out how
to turn off the music, I didn't tell myself I'm stupid.
Instead I said, God has already pursued you
with resources, some of whom are right here.
He will quite you. And the music with
That is so good.
Alright. So hope
that went well for you.
Just having another, uh, time of
meeting each other at the point of our deeper thoughts
and feelings and considerations
that we might have corrective emotional experiences for
what the world that we live in has produced.
Okay. And we can't count on that from our culture
or, uh, even always our, even our neighbors.
But we want to be able to count on that from each other
and to know how to restore times when we have missed,
missed that mark.
So I put up here on the board, um,
just a context for what are we doing in this course.
Really a lot of this has to do
with taking us from a rational
and behavioral, uh, way of approaching us each other
with expectations to one that's truly more relational,
where I'm really hearing you and seeing you
and not judging you.
Um, but where the focus really goes to needs
that you have, that I more than anybody else on planet Earth
am called to serve those legitimate God ordained needs.
Okay? And that's a very different approach.
It's almost like saying, okay, Jesus,
how are we gonna love Joyce today?
And I think I blew it yesterday.
So what do I need to do about that? Does that make sense?
Mm-Hmm. And he's not beating me
up over the mistakes.
He's saying, let's do that again. Let's do that over.
Does that make sense? It really makes a pretty good
parenting model, by the way.
Mm-Hmm. Um, so, um,
want to transition to, um,
one other aspect of this.
I'm just checking myself to see if I'm,
if I've covered everything that I want to cover on that.
I think so. Ah, so what do you do
to try to repair
wounds that might have actually contributed
to some feelings about
oneself like Joyce was sharing
that her criticism was kind of tapping into a vulnerability
that I already had and kind of adding to that.
So clearly what you just heard her reference when she
basically said, I repented of that.
She didn't use that word today, but she did.
And the word repent means to turn around
and go the opposite direction.
So it, it implies not just a words that I say, it's a change
working from the inside out in me.
I am moved with godly sorrow for how
that has been hurtful to you.
That was part of the material
that you read in the last week or so.
And based on that movement in my heart called Godly sorrow,
that's what's motivating the needed change in my behavior.
If I get to godly sorrow, which is not
condemnation, see the difference?
Godly sorrow is tied to something I did or failed to do.
And it's very much related to some behavior of mine.
Either something I did or something I didn't do.
And I should feel conviction over
that if it was wrong.
But conviction is not condemnation.
Conviction says that isn't living according to my way.
Let's repent of that and get this right moving forward.
And by the way, you need to go care for your spouse
because they've already been hurt by that.
So that's part of the what to do with condemnation.
It's not just about condemnation's not tied
so much to what you do.
It is tied to who you think you are.
See, it's not about behavior, it's about identity
or sense of identity.
That's why I can be a born again
Christ follower, imperfect as I am,
but still Christ has come to abide in me.
His sacrifice on the cross applies to me.
And yet I can still think
things about myself
that are very different from what he says.
So one of the ways that we can work with that is to
embrace the truth of his way of loving me,
this unconditional love.
The other though, is to experience more of what's good
to experience about who you are.
See, I said it's tied to identity.
If it's condemnation, a sense of I'm not enough.
Well, who knows you best of all on planet earth,
apart from God, who's that gonna be?
Me? Spouse. Yeah. Yeah.
Joyce is gonna know me, warts and all.
Um, your spouse probably knows you better than anybody.
Okay? And what if
they are regularly speaking
truth to you about what God sees in you?
That's good affirmation.
Not just about something you did once.
Congratulations, you graduated from this place
or this place or whatever.
That's all good. But where they look in your heart
and say, I see great stability in you.
Or I think you've got
determination that a lot of people don't have, whatever
that trait is, sensitivity,
Um, Loyalty,
whatever that is.
So I want to give you just another minute
or two to give thought to
what is it Maybe a couple of things
that I could say this is true of you.
And I may have said it before, but I'm saying it again.
I see this in you.
Okay? And I hope that you do that
for your kids also.
Mm-Hmm. 'cause they'll probably give you opportunity to have
to deal with some correction.
This would be an affirmation. Okay?
So just ask the Lord to bring
to your mind a couple of things.
Uh, I would often illustrate,
uh, something like this exercise, uh,
by pointing out things about Joyce
that were about her diligence and her determination
and, um, her responsibility.
And those were always true.
But what's fun is kind of watching for, what do I see now
that might be even different than that?
This girl can't learn about
somebody who's in need without sending them a card.
Can I tell on you who you're sending one to?
I guess, who am I sending one to? I dunno.
Kenzie. Oh
Yeah. Okay.
Um,
I mentioned we watched sports.
Well, we watched OU softball, uh,
some games they were playing.
And there's this one player
that's been there quite a time, uh, happens.
We know she's a believer.
And, uh, so George just said
after watch game, I'm gonna send Kenzie a card.
And next thing I know, she's asking for a stamp.
I mean, she just gets it done.
I'd think about it for about three weeks.
And I'm just saying that's not only diligence, that's
empathy and kindness and friendliness.
And she's not expecting that girl who's kind of a celebrity.
She's not expecting her to do anything for Joyce.
So I'm just saying that's a character trait.
She sees something that would be a way to touch somebody.
And she acts on not so much this guy. Mm-Hmm.
Little different guy. Mm-Hmm. Okay.
So that was an affirmation hurt.
So just take a couple minutes here.
I think I've bought you enough time, uh, to think something.
Okay. And for,
and for you guys to, uh, your spouses aren't here today.
Maybe just make a note or two
or something you could share later.
Okay. Alright. Go ahead.
Can I borrow your help again?
Stop the music. I
Didn't see how you pump that up. There's
A little play button up here
and this tiny little spot. It's hard to see.
Oh, okay. When you click that
Pause here.
Okay. Thank you.
I think we can just close your hands.
Okay.
Yesterday. That's okay. It's just a clip.
So the last time we taught this class, thank you.
The last time we taught this class, um,
we were running short of time that particular week.
And so I kind of glossed over the part on sexual intimacy
and I got scolded afterwards,
Condemned, Not quiet,
Scolded Held accountable
Holy Spirit type stuff.
And, and it, and it was basically, uh, a guy in the class
who, um, had heard
enough people either totally dismissed talking about sexual
intimacy in the church,
or, um,
they came from an old traditional way of looking at things
that didn't really bless sexual intimacy as part
of God's desire, that we would experience
closeness in a way that was truly mutually
validating and satisfying.
And so that's clearly his will for us.
Um, and so I decided I'm not gonna make that mistake again.
I don't want anybody holding me accountable like that,
but seriously, um, I'm, I'm going to,
uh, just cover a few things about it.
One of the things that helped me the most in terms of this
is I was clearly raised in, uh,
a much easier environment than what kids have today.
I mean, I just can't imagine being a parent of a child today
and trying to help them navigate all the things
that are pressed upon them through media, through, uh,
peers, et cetera.
But we had our own share of
not good things going on back when we were growing up.
But, um, I just remember there being a lot
of focus on, uh,
sex being something that we take
or we have, which makes it like a possession.
Does that make sense? In a general sense?
It's like if we view it as something we have
or do, uh, rather than something
that is part of how we grow
and share, then we're, we're, we're probably
actually building in a little bit of performance pressure
on one or both of us.
And that'll get in the way.
So we don't want it to be something we take
or something we have, uh,
definitely not something we keep score on, okay?
'cause that puts a performance issue into it.
But it's rather, it's something that we are becoming,
we're becoming more free to express our intimacy
and our love for one another,
including in physical closeness.
Okay? So just kind of a bit of a mindset there.
God intended our sexual intimacy to honor him,
but also to be mutually fulfilling to both spouses.
Now that among other things,
we've already talked about differences in personality
and how, if I'm gonna meet Joyce's relational
needs, not talking sexual needs right now,
but relational needs, if I'm gonna meet those needs, I need
to meet them according to what really is relevant
to her rather than the way I would want that need met.
Okay? But when it comes to sex, we never want to
expect someone to participate in something
that isn't comfortable for them.
So that's kind of a ground rule, is there might be something
that you would experience as pleasurable,
but it would actually create stress
or, uh, anxiety for your spouse.
And we'd say, don't do it, then take that off the table.
Okay? It ain't worth it
to make somebody feel uncomfortable in order to
experience pleasure in a certain way.
So that's kind of boldly me speaking something that, um,
was very important for us to understand too.
But on the other hand, um,
within the scope of what are both of you
okay with, um, learn from each other?
Well, what, what would make an ideal,
uh, sexual encounter with me?
What would make that better for you?
What would make that enjoyable and pleasurable for you
and honoring to you as well as to God?
Okay? So in a minute I'm gonna pass out some worksheets,
but this is homework.
I think I timed this about right,
so I'm not skirting the issue, but, um, I was
Getting ready to volunteer the Brooks if
you needed somebody to.
No, that could get a lot of us some trouble.
Dangerous, okay? So they, they actually developed a, a way,
uh, kind of a questionnaire for you
to individually reflect on
and then actually express your own preferences about
what would make this, um, experience pleasurable.
I remember David Ferguson,
who's got a real good sense of humor.
Uh, do you remember this, uh, saying that
when his wife came back with her list,
it started with two weeks beforehand,
flirt with me two weeks before,
and then I, I may mess this up, up calendaring,
These items, right?
Yeah. And then she had, you know,
and then, uh, let's have some time on the patio talking.
And basically she was coming up with a lot
of relational things
long before we get close to the bedroom, okay?
Like maybe days before,
Because That's actually helping her feel loved
and cared for and respected and so forth.
And David said, I looked at my sheet for my preferences
and he said, number one, get naked.
And, uh, so
by in large part,
God wired us differently
and this is one of the places where that really matters.
So, um, just taking
that into consideration, you each fill this out,
share it with one another, not right
before you're going to bed, okay?
In other words, this is
to really more deeply understand each other, okay?
Um, problem for many couples is
that the only time they talk about sex
is when they're frustrated.
That make sense? I mean, we've been there
and so we're actually encouraging you, number one, see it
as this is a blessing.
Obviously, if you look at the scripture, obviously intended
by God as a gift, um,
but oftentimes we aren't meeting the relational needs
along the way, and therefore it becomes something we do.
And often something we do when we don't necessarily want
to, okay?
And that's not what we want to aim for. Okay?
So lots of freedom, lots of care.
Um, So the lack
of open communication about our sexual relationship,
and it is maybe the most vulnerable
or one of the most vulnerable things to talk about,
because I would say for men
and women, uh, it is one of the most vulnerable places
where all it would take is a disgusting sigh
to destroy your feelings.
You know, something like that. A negative, uh, comment.
So we want it to bless both people and
therefore my job is to bless her.
Her job is to bless me
so we're not taking from one another. That make sense?
I look back to when I was a little girl, I know,
don't ever remember a discussion about it with my mother,
never, or about the time
that I would've been starting a period.
We didn't talk about that either. Mm-Hmm.
Yeah. So that's what I bring to this relationship.
Yeah. So that,
that might've helped if we had had those kinds
of caring conversations with our parents.
Um, and even then when I, you know, I,
I might have needed more help than that,
but the bottom line is we're trying to bless this
as something that is truly a gift from God.
And yet you can see all the focus we put on relational needs
would be so helpful when it comes to our sexual intimacy.
So just wanna lift that part up.
Um, Any thoughts, questions?
Okay. Um,
there are two handouts, guys.
Get one. Girls get you.
There Should be enough here.
So is this, what's on that barcode on page 1 35?
I think some of us had this, I have not yet.
It should be the same thing. Didn't have this.
It mine is yours.
I'm
Glad you mentioned that. I need
to restate that.
Wait, What is that 1 35?
1 35. Okay. So if you look in your books on page
1 35, Uh, I
Think there's a reference There is at the bottom.
Does it say and Yes. Okay.
So in ER's book, there's a barcode down below,
but in Ed's book there wasn't.
Okay, well it is because of a different printing. Yeah.
Okay. They, they omitted it accidentally.
So if you don't have a QR code,
what I just passed out to you, is it?
Mm-Hmm. Okay.
That'll get you by. But, uh, apparently in this batch
of books we've got two different printers.
So they did fix that.
But, uh, I'm glad you mentioned that
'cause I was just assuming it's been fixed.
Thoughts, questions. Is this working?
Is this okay? Yeah. Alright.
We got one more meeting and it's kind of a wrap up meeting,
but, um, you've got a few more days in your book
and, uh, I just encourage you, um, uh,
keep the process, if you've ever gotten behind
during these weeks, uh, just encourage you, uh,
circle the wagons
and pick up those other days, uh, later on.
And, uh, we just want to kind of serve you
by getting you into this material as well as we can.
And, uh, do you have anything else you wanted to say?
You want to close this in prayer? Sure. Okay.
What a wonderful group of people we've had this time.
We thank you for bringing each and every couple to us
and pray that we'll be able to, Bruce
and I to continue to live out these principles
to honor you and every couple here.
And we pray it in Jesus' name. Amen.